you're not dating a single mom that's
20 years older than you with three kids
in here thank god no
i'm uh i'm 24 right now and for the time
being i'm i've
i'm kind of going mgtow for a bit just
to kind of get my [ __ ] in order but okay
so this isn't really about me um this is
about my friend he
was doing some works he was just working
at home over the summer
and this serbian chick kind of came
around and started
being a waitress at the same place he
was working
and he started just like banging her and
i was like okay good job robert
and this guy's been my long time friend
since childhood so he's pretty special
and uh i thought it was just like a
casual thing this was about a year ago
and uh nothing really came out of it he
didn't mention her much
and then i went and saw him over this
last christmas
and he he told me how he went to serbia
during the pandemic so he went to serbia
during the pandemic
to see this chick and he spent two weeks
over there with her
did you call him a simp
this guy has a fragile ego so like if
you
try to like insult him in any way like
that he gets mad and i'm really afraid
that i'm just going to like
lose a friend right out of this which
you want to lose them
so essentially but i was like okay he's
going over to serbia maybe he's just
having a good time with her right
uh but all the pictures he showed me um
like i watched this podcast with rolo
about body language
and you know how like a lot of the time
the girls looking at the camera and the
dudes kissing the chick
right like it all just rubbed me the
wrong way
and like for every one picture of them
together there was like 15 of her at
every spot with all the classic insta
model poses you know
and he was just totally swooning over
this chick and uh
after that i'm like okay well this is
kind of cringy but you know
he's so he's in a long distance relation
relationship with her now oh it's a long
distance relationship now
i thought it was just like a casual
thing but now he's full-blown he talks
to her every day face time for like two
hours how old is he
uh he's my age he's my he's 24. so he's
24.
it's probably the only girl he's ever
been with or
he's a handful he's been with girls all
throughout high school and he's not a
bad looking dude
actually but he uh he's he's so
he he'll flaunt every chick he's with in
front of us all the time we're like cool
robert like good for you man but like
he always has like the next biggest
thing and he's like totally into her and
then she dumps him
that's like how it goes like every time
and the biggest kicker
becomes your friend again after he gets
stumped yeah exactly and then he has
time for me
yeah but okay so what's the question
here he told me he's saving up for an
engagement ring
oh [ __ ] yeah so i i i don't know how to
go about doing this like dude
she has other options you're not her
only option she probably has
five dudes that are saving up for an
engagement ring for her
and she lips serbia serbia yeah and
where does he live
uh monterey california holy [ __ ] that's
a flight
yeah what is that like 20 hours yeah so
he went and flew over there and spent
two weeks with her and blew up like
he told me he spent like 10 grand over
two weeks with her
and i'm like uh she's in her early
twenties i don't know she is [ __ ]
she's smoking hot she's really hot but
yeah like they don't have to put
themselves together over there i mean
the eastern euro chicks are
usually smoke shows but i mean you know
you like
tell them to look at her mom because you
know these like russian bears
you know it's the reason why they call
them russian bears but anyway
um so i mean like where do you start
with this you got a friend that's about
to make the dumbest decision in his
entire life
exactly take him take him down to the
family courthouse
and say hey man let's go on a field trip
let's just go see what happens to
fathers
in divorce law um
you know just i don't know make a joke
out of it like you know bring a drink
smoke a joint whatever something like
just just try to try to lighten the tone
but show him what happens when these
muppets
march into a slaughterhouse and get
married to women that are totally out of
their league
because if this chick's a smoke show
she's a 10 out of 10 is what you're
saying
like a 9 yeah
where's robert at on the scale uh
i'd probably say he's maybe a point or
two below me
okay so he's not great so it's
so it's okay to call him a simp i guess
but uh
yeah i mean you're you're you're either
gonna lose a friend over this
and he's and he's gonna go and do it
anyway at which point he's gonna come
back and be
hey jonathan it didn't work out you're
right seven years later and i'm kind of
[ __ ] i've got a kid now and
she won't let me see him and all that
kind of stuff but
at least you've at least you said what
you needed to say
right like you got the words out i i
yeah my plan was pretty much
wait until like he's actually like hey
jonathan
my wedding's on this date you should go
and then i'm like okay let's have a
fireside chat kind of thing no
don't don't let it get to that point
don't even let it get to the point where
he buys the ring
okay all right there's a video on
youtube somewhere about engagement rings
and what a scam they are and just
basically like
dig that up and say you want to spend x
amount of dollars on on
on dinosaur [ __ ] like that's what you
want to do i had my parents show me
their engagement ring and i was just
like
and and and give it to a chick that's
a 20-hour flight away that's probably
smashing other dudes and
possibly talking to a bunch of other
guys simultaneous like a long-distance
relationship is not a relationship
i actually have a video on my channel
about long-distance relationships
yeah but dig that up and send that to
him and then just see if he's kind of
receptive to that like he's like huh
that's interesting or if he's like [ __ ]
that guy you know
if he doesn't want to hear anything then
you're basically going to talk to a wall
but if he
has some openness to it like huh well
that's kind of interesting
i didn't really consider that then maybe
you might have a little bit of an
audience but
i mean there's a few things that you can
do but usually what what ends up
happening in
in situations like this where guys want
to save their friends from making stupid
choices
they end up losing a friend the friend
makes a stupid choice anyway
and then they see it for what it is and
then you know a few years down the road
they'll come back and be like yeah
you're right i was dumb
a little damaged yeah i'm i'm i was dumb
i was broke and now i totally screwed up
my life and
you're right sorry anyway
um there's not much you can do with him
you know beyond that you know it's like
i said earlier you know you can lead a
horse to water but you can't make them
drink so
try to give them the best that you can
but you know lead lead by example
yourself is
really the best thing that you can do i
try yeah and it's okay hey
listen you know for for a guy like you
from your perspective
it's good that you understand these
concepts and you're in monk mode and
you're working on yourself
but at the end of the day um you're
going to lose friends along the way
like the people that you hang out with
like i'm in my late 40s i don't hang out
with almost
i have one friend that i can remember
from my 20s or from high school
and i see him like once every two like
he messaged me because he got this new
[ __ ] truck it's like a 300
000 custom-made truck with like this
big-ass motor i can't remember what it's
called but it's basically like an old
land rover
defender that's remade and modernized he
you know they call him because he's like
hey dude you got to come see this truck
i'm like
all right get together like that's when
i talk to him right
but aside from that these these people
that you hang out with
right now the amount of resources and
brain power that you're using thinking
about this
to even call on this tonight and the
consideration that you're putting into
it all
it's like this will not even be
something on the roadmap in 15 20 years
coming for you
yeah that's that's true yeah all right
yep okay matt thanks for hopping on see
thank you
you